[Musique]
à
aux états unis on ne va pas voir un film
on va au cinéma et les salles de cinéma
quelle qu'elle soit font partie
intégrante de l'expérience les etats
unis c'est le continent qui réinvente en
permanence le cinéma celui qui a inventé
les multiplexes aseptisé et fait rentrer
pop corn et boissons noir pétillante
saturé de sucre dans les salles
mais l'étoile de l'amérique
peuvent-elles encore sûr pas y at il
encore un moyen de voir des films ici un
moyen à échelle humaine sans avoir la
sensation d'être le cobaye d'un centre
commercial mais
pour le savoir voici un road movie
inédit à travers les toiles de
l'amérique en attendant je vais
installer ma toile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à new york que mon histoire
commence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de nuit à times square quartier des
théâtres et des cinémas la cité
m'apparaît encore plus comme une toile
de fond idéale
cinématographiquement cette ville est
hallucinante tout me donne envie de
filmer
[Musique]
et demain c'est une balade à travers les
trésors cachés de la ville qui m'attend
les sublimes salles de cinéma englouti
en attente d'être restaurée démolis ou
transformées elle constitue un véritable
patrimoine historique celui de l'âge
d'or du cinéma américain
[Musique]
dans les années 20 vingt mille cinq
cents salles sont construites dans tout
le pays par les cinq plus gros studios
de l'époque 200 rien qu'à new york à
commencer par celle ci le lendemain
qu'ils allaient sébile son propriétaire
qui m'ouvre les portes de son paradis
je suis vraiment content d'être là cet
endroit est sublime
l'extérieur c'est incroyable c'est
quelque chose tout droit sorti du passé
quelque chose que l'on ne reverra plus 1
j'ai hâte de voir
c'est renversant
c'est ce que je préfère voir la tête des
gens quand ils entrent ici alors
messieurs enchanté je suis craig
je suis architecte et historien
je suis aussi membre d'une association
qui regroupe près de 1000 personnes
notre but est de préserver ses salles de
cinéma ancien
tout comme son vieil ami bill craig est
aussi un passionné de cinéma il sera mon
guide à travers les movie palace comme
on les appelle ici
[Musique]
regardez tous ces fauteuils imaginez
2500 personnes assises ici deux fois par
soir ce qui faisait vingt mille
spectateurs chaque semaine ça donne une
idée du style de vie new york et à cette
époque c'est incroyable
sa bile craig et les bénévoles du
quartier la salle est en cours de
restauration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma visite se poursuit à newark banlieue
pauvre de la ville
[Musique]
oh
derrière une boutique de vêtements bon
marché se cache un véritable titanic
ça c'est le destin de beaucoup de grands
cinémas aux états unis you work était
une très grande ville la plus grande du
new-jersey mais lorsqu'elle a été
supplanté par manhattan cette banlieue
est devenue très dangereuse les gens ne
voulaient plus venir ici
ont préféré rester près de chez soi
aller au cinéma à côté de sa maison
c'est comme ça que ce genre de cinéma a
été fermé
pourrait ouvrir cette salle ici il
faudrait beaucoup d'argent et beaucoup
d'amour
[Musique]
construit en 1923 avec ses deux salles
l'une au dessus de l'autre le propre
tort fut le premier multiplex new
yorkais son histoire s'est arrêtée en
moi j'en ai des frissons
voilà c'est un lieu complètement
incroyable on a l'impression qu'il ya
des fantômes qui plane autour de nous
c'est hallucinant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
on rêve s'achève dans le quartier juif
de brooklyn dans un magasin de meuble ou
un cinéma sert depuis 1973 entreposer
des chaises vides sous plastique ce
cinéma s'appelait l'universal
même complètement défoncée rouillé je
suis surpris de voir que ces vaisseaux
ont étrangement survécu au temps et à la
pression immobilière de la ville
sait pas trop où je vais mais en tout
cas j'entends des pigeons voilà fâchent
je crois que je me faire attaquer par
des pignons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais sur le toit d'un cinéma en plein
brooklyn c'est énorme
[Musique]
new york
c'est la ville où une femme à simuler un
orgasme dans un restaurant ou un
chauffeur de taxi s'est rasé le crâne où
elle a rendez vous avec lui au sens
deuxième étage de l'empiré state
building bref new york c'est la plus
grande et la plus haute toile de
l'amérique et tous les niveaux de ce
gigantesque espace vertical que new york
se vouent au cinéma d'ailleurs il ya un
type ici qu'il a bien compris ses
marques depuis plusieurs années il a
installé sa toile sur les toits de la
ville et le temps d'un film on ne bouge
plus ce qui est plutôt rare ici
[Musique]
il y aller
et
[Musique]
voilà plus de dix ans que marc a créé
les rooftops world series tout a
commencé après la projection d'un court
métrage entre potes sur le toit de son
appartement ma porte est ouverte et les
gens du quartier sont montés
voici marque sa casquette à carreaux sa
chemise à manches courtes son vélo avec
sa salle de cinéma à ciel ouvert il a
créé l'événement brancher un an câble
l'été très new-yorkais ça fait aussi du
vélo sur le toit
tout ça c'est brooklyn
oui c'est brooklyn on est environ 10
minutes en métro ou un goy vélo de
manhattan et si tu marches sur le pont
de manhattan cela te prend 25 minutes
qu'est ce qui se passe ce soir tu vas
projeté quel film un film qui s'appelle
etienne c'est la première de ce film ce
soir il a été réalisé par jef mizushima
c'est très drôle décalé un plus petit
budget c'est l'histoire d'un type qui
fait un dernier voyage à vélo avec son
hamster je recherche toujours ce genre
de film
on veut trouver des films uniques qu'on
ne voit pas ailleurs des films très
personnels et intimes plutôt réalisé
avec peu de moyens des films qu'on ne
verrait jamais dans des salles de cinéma
classique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à new york il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'espacé public pas beaucoup de parcs
alors les toits ont toujours été un
refuge pour les habitants de cette ville
pour nous c'est un peu comme une
métaphore
monter sur un toit et avoir une
perception différente du monde bien nous
on monte sur les toits et on projette
des films qui propose un autre regard
sur le monde
quand on travaille dans l'art ce que
l'on souhaite le plus c'est que les gens
se sentent concernés quand on vient
regarder un film un peu étrange sur un
toit on s'en souvient vraiment c'est un
pur moment artistique à tous les points
de vue on ne projette pas des films dans
un cinéma mais au coeur même de la
communauté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as la face
jacques bizard
à new york tout est vraiment possible
voir un film sur un hamster en fin de
vie tout en haut d'un building
pas sûr que cela le soit ailleurs
[Musique]
changement de décor changement de monde
et de genre
à 2700 kilomètres de là au pays de l'or
noir on regarde les films autrement un
mythe indissociable de l'histoire du
cinéma américain
ouais
[Musique]
ah ah
ce faire un film ce soir on va aller se
faire une toile
une toile particulière on peut aller
bien l'américaine
dans les années 30 l'américain moyen
découvre tout ce qu'il est possible de
faire dans sa voiture manger sans en
sortir faire ses courses aller à la
banque et voir un film alors forcément
en moi j'ai choisi la dernière solution
voir un film dans sa voiture alors
allons voir un film
voilà comment ont surgi plus de 4000
écran blanc posé au milieu de nulle part
aux quatre coins du pays les fermetures
aylwin c'est dans un état conservateur
qui se voudrait garant de certaines
vieilles valeurs américaines le texas
qu'il en reste 16
le galaxy
trop la classe
ah la vache à quatre écrans one two
three four
c'est parti
alors bonjour quel film robin des bois a
much is it c'est combien ces six dollars
6 2 ok rigueur
c'est l'écran numéro deux là bas ok 88.3
ok c'est la station de radio pour
écouter le film bonne soirée ok merci
beaucoup
alors l'écran numéro deux il n'existe
donc c'est celui-là
[Musique]
y est
scarlett dans un film c'est excellent
[Musique]
bienvenue dans un gros clichés et dans
le plus grand drive in du coin avec ses
speakerphone datant des années 40
l'amérique des drive-in c'est
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle ici
l'americana en résumé hot-dogs apple pie
chevrolet une véritable façon de vivre
où l'on n'hésite pas à conduire deux
heures pour aller voir un film et ce
sont des milliers de voitures qui chaque
week end remplissent le terrain vague de
galaxies les heureux propriétaires se
sont eux martin et sa femme marchant de
passionnés qui ont bâti eux mêmes leurs
drive in l1 nice et nancy aux hommes
stéphane bonjour je suis marche
les superbes of driving soit il est pas
mal enfin moi je le préfère la nuit
quand tout est éclairée
[Musique]
règle d'or dans un drive in il est
interdit d'amener son pique nique tout
se consomme sur place du pop corn au
hamburger et c'est surtout grâce à ça
que marche a fait tourner la boutique
les gens viennent de tous les horizons
beaucoup viennent aussi avec leurs
enfants c'est très libre personne ne se
soucie de savoir s'il est habillée comme
une fausse se comporte comme il faut
il ya aussi beaucoup de gays et de
lesbiennes et qui aiment cet endroit
parce qu'ils savent qu'on ne va pas les
regarder de travers ou les juger ici si
vous voulez boire une bière et voir un
film c'est possible si vous voulez fumée
voir un film n'a pas de problème c'est
tranquille est
et ce qu'il y a des gens qui viennent
ils font l'amour ici
ah ça peut arriver de temps en temps
[Musique]
pourquoi vous aimez venir ici
venir dans un drive in c'est comme faire
un voyage dans le temps
en plus c'est là que ma femme et moi
avons eu notre premier rendez vous ah
oui c'est joli il ya 25 ans exelon c'est
pas comme dans les salles de cinéma on
n'est pas collés les uns aux autres on
ne dérange personne pour aller aux
toilettes
vous aimez voir des films ici oui c'est
beau
c'est romantique ça peut être romantique
c'est pour ça que vous emmenez votre lit
oui c'est ça
[Musique]
vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut oui je
crois les hamburgers l'époque comme des
bonbons les boissons la radio
mardi martin pourquoi tu as envie de
construire ton propre drive in
quand j'étais enfant j'y allais souvent
avec mes parents j'adorais ça à cause de
leur travail j'ai voyagé à travers tout
le pays et j'ai assisté à la destruction
progressive et drive in mais je savais
qu'il ne restait quelques uns année
alors à partir de pièces détachées
d'anciens drive in j'ai construit mien
pour faire partie du mythe moi aussi
tu sais j'aime les vieilles voitures
j'aime les gens c'est la meilleure façon
de combiner les deux
je pense que les années 50 c'était la
plus belle époque aux états unis et je
veux que donner cette impression venant
ici
alors si vous voulez voyager dans le
temps il faut venir ici
[Musique]
les différentes c'est difficile de
résister aux multiplexes
on essaie d'attirer un public
complètement différente les gens qui
vont aux résines ne vont pas dans les
salles et s'ils ne sont pas ici c'est
qu'ils sont chez eux devant leur
télévision beaucoup de gens viennent ici
pour profiter du restaurant mais en plus
ils ont ce spectacle qui va avec quand
lé film alors toi tu aimes le cinéma
ouais j'ai toujours adoré simple bon on
n'a pas trop le temps de voir des films
parce qu'on travaille tout le temps et
toute la nuit
c'est la première fois dans un drive in
oui c'est ma première fois depuis que je
suis tout petit je rêve de voir un film
dans un drive in
je suis super content d'être là c'est
dans les films que tu les a découverts
ouais c'est ça american graffiti oui
tous ces films
brise
et là tu vois là prêts à vivre son rêve
[Musique]
première chose j'allume la radio
pour avoir le son
hélas
l'hymne national américain
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
après l'amérique des happy days c'est
celle de la quatrième dimension qui
m'attend direction al baker qui la plus
grande ville du nouveau mexique là où
dans les années 40 a été fabriqué la
première bombe atomique
[Musique]
e
quand j'arrive il est 5h30 du matin
la ville coincée entre le rio grande et
le désert et les montagnes est étrange
et tandis qu'un corps flottent dans une
piscine trois jeunes types mène une
double vie la journée ils sont profs de
fac et le matin avant que la chaleur et
la lumière ne soit écrasante il tente
des films ce sont les fondateurs d'une
institution ici babe films les films de
la cave
je m'appelle calais fisher et
aujourd'hui je vais faire un film je
vais probablement faire l'acteur aussi
j'ai 26 ans je
suis michael j'ai 28 ans et je suis
l'assistant de khaled
je m'appelle brian reed et ce qu'ils ont
négligé 24 ans et aujourd'hui c'est moi
qui filme
aujourd'hui nous allons réaliser un
court métrage de science fiction il va y
avoir une poursuite
de la plagne et criques
et je crois qu'on va avoir des hommes
soit
bonjour je m'appelle stéphane je vais
participer à un film expérimental
j'imagine que tu l'as fait des
recherches toute la journée n'a rien
trouvé tu es fatigué épuisé tu veux
rentrer chez toi et tu penses que tu
peux encore trouver quelque chose
met toi bien dans la peau de son
personnage
ça tourne on ne regarde pas la caméra
et
action
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est bien lieu
et
regarde
lève toi et marche
[Musique]
tu peux m'en raconter encore l'histoire
du film
alors nous devons tous quitté la terre
parce que des scientifiques ont préféré
faire des expériences sur le soleil
plutôt que de trouver une nouvelle
source d'énergie
mais ils ont foiré donc le soleil a
commencé à grossir et la chaleur est
insupportable
les scientifiques ont construit des
cubes géants
une lune de saturne nommé titan
il ya toute notre mémoire a été faste
c'est un acteur mon pote
et caleb et sa bande ne font pas que des
films il les projette aussi et pas
n'importe où leur salle c'est là qu'à
vous
c'est ici wizman feus
c'est vrai
comme tu peux le voir il y a des
milliers de films en 16 mm amassés au
fil des ans ce qui constitue l'une des
plus grandes collections du sud-ouest
un stock légué par l'école publique
d'albuquerque ce sont des films sur
l'éducation qui était utilisé dans les
écoles publiques et ils allaient être
jetés
les productions j'utilise une partie de
ses archives et je filme aussi beaucoup
ici dans cette cave
une autre partie des films que nous
faisons est constituée exclusivement de
ses films 16 mm sur lesquels on a
dessiné et fédérer gurs
et on fait aussi des films purement
expérimentaux
cette façon de faire des films tu aimes
faire des films comme ça oui des films
faits maison pas avec beaucoup d'argent
mais avec beaucoup d'amour
[Musique]
et
bienvenue à tous ce soir c'est la
première de notre film human rishon
millière j'espère que vous aimerez
j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
nice aux côtes et à se faire
et du point
[Musique]
m
ce
je
[Musique]
frd
dans la cave de big man film on ne se
prend jamais au sérieux
et
on ne fait que célébrer leur grade le
cinéma ça grouille dans les cerveaux et
il est évident que tout ce talent ne
restera pas sous la terre longtemps
[Musique]
et
mon voyage continue au coeur de
l'amérique est toujours plus de cinéma
ici c'est celui des longs plans de bord
de route ou des personnages en fuite
créer des histoires qui m'ont toujours
fasciné
[Musique]
et
je
[Musique]
là où d histoire s'achève tandis que
d'autres recommence la mienne continue
[Musique]
500 kilomètres plus loin en arizona
après le rio grande est ma conquête de
l'ouest qui me donne le sentiment d'être
au coeur d'une toile de john ford l'un
des pères du western
flagstaff un vrai décor de cinéma avec
sagar sa rue principale son saloon et
son hôtel où les légendes du cinéma
américains dormaient quand elle tournait
des films dans
alors bientôt montrer vista merci les
gars vous avez une chambre de libre pour
ce soir alors oui j'ai bien sûr monsieur
voici une liste de toutes les stars qui
ont dormi ici
c'est ryan russell pour les hommes
préfèrent les blondes
largué bol
absolument il était là pour autant en
emporte le vent alors je veux la chambre
de klinguer veulent pas de problème
[Musique]
oui
nous sommes un peu comme
le wat qui m'a aidé
keita
dernier a répété de temps dans port plus
bas
[Musique]
en voici à flagstaff dans cette petite
ville du far west des centaines de films
ont été tournés et le plus étonnant
c'est celui de camille b les beats
étonnant parce que camille à 14 ans
qu'elle est indienne et que son film de
26 minutes fait le tour des festivals de
cinéma aux états unis et demain camille
nous accorde un sacré privilégie qu elle
nous emmène dans sa réserve à la
rencontre de sa grand mère qui lui a
respiré son fils un an la tendance unis
mantis burger parce que les troubles
[Musique]
camille c'est elle et nous roulons en
pays navarro dans la plus grande réserve
indienne des états unis avec ses
quarante mille kilomètres carrés de
terres rouges
c'est une magnifique ici
j'adore cet endroit j'ai grandi ici je
le connais par coeur mais tous les jours
je découvre quelque chose de nouveau
camille maumey noblot canyon là où elle
a tourné une partie de son film la
légende raconte que si les navarro ne
respectaient pas leur culture ils
étaient transformés en pierre ici même
[Musique]
ici pas de touristes en short et
appareil photo autour du cou uniquement
des visages en pierre qui nous observent
camille sa petite soeur son père et moi
même
l'instant est privilégiée et troublant
tout comme le premier film de camille
dans les pas de yellow wons un court
métrage sur l'histoire de son arrière
arrière arrière grand mère et de sa
communauté victimes de l'oppression et
c'est aussi camille qui joue le rôle de
son ancêtre
[Musique]
fait dans son film je règle mon pas sur
les pas de camille pour aller rencontrer
sa grand mère
[Musique]
lorsque j'arrive elle est assise devant
sa maison elle ne me regarde pas elle
ignore ma caméra
il me faudra une bonne heure avant de
pouvoir lui parler
je suis mal à l'aise intimider
elle est mon inspiration pour tous
un jour je lui ai demandé comment
c'était quand elle était petite comme je
ne parle pas trop le navarre où je n'ai
pas vraiment tout compris alors je suis
revenu la voir avec mon père il a fait
la traduction et c'est comme ça que j'ai
entendu parler pour la première fois de
la vie de galop ou même et c'est comme
ça qu'est né mon film
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle pense de camille et de
son film qui parle de son histoire sa
famille
est
une
idole johnny guitare
et
au banjo
à
l'attaqué
et
elle est fière du travail de sa petite
fille et elle veut qu'elle continue à le
faire
chypre a miami il n'aura pas fini de
raconter toutes ces histoires quand elle
aura les cheveux blancs
[Musique]
grâce à son film camille redonne le
sourire à sa grand mère elle a aussi été
invité à intégrer le collège le plus
prestigieux de californie pour y
apprendre le cinéma
[Musique]
non chaque mélomane et enterrés ici
quelque part
adhara
[Musique]
je suis en train d'écrire une autre
histoire en ce moment
[Musique]
raconté que des histoires proches de
saltigué logo man
show et montrer que l'on peut exister
staff allégations et parler de tout ça
en dehors de la norme d'hollywood
beaucoup de gens pensent que nous les
indiens nous vivons toujours dans des
tipis que nous dansons toujours autour
d'un feu
c'est faux s'il ya bien des gens dans le
monde qui doivent utiliser les médias ce
doit être les minorités qui n'ont pas
accès ce sont eux qui en ont le plus
besoin car ils ont beaucoup de choses à
montrer à raconter leurs histoires
peuvent être incroyables
alors faites attention à ce genre là
je vais faire attention à toi je
l'espère il suffit d'un seul spectateur
pour que l'histoire sera racontée
à seulement 14 ans l'ami porte désormais
en elle l'espoir d'un courant
cinématographique dont seuls jusqu'à
présent robert redford se préoccupait le
cinéma des natives
[Musique]
à 635 km de là se trouve l'autre ville
américaine du cinéma
ma ville où tous les gros studios se
sont implantés où toutes les stars
vivent ou le mot cinéma rime avec profit
voici à los angeles
[Musique]
que ce soit dans une piscine délavé
évident le long de ces freeway sur ses
célèbres murs peints los angeles suicide
des imaginaires multiples et complexes
et fait l'objet de chaque côté de
l'écran d'une expérience esthétique
stupéfiante
c'est ici que james dean a eu la fureur
de vivre
c'est ici que se trouve le plus célèbre
cinéma du monde le mann chinese 6 heures
c'est ici que superman on son petit
déjeuner
[Musique]
ici c'est la ville de tous les drames
réel aux fictionnel la ville où les
toiles peuvent être très surprenante
[Musique]
par exemple à los angeles on peut voir
un film comme ça avec sa glacière
entouré de stars qui repose en paix ou
presque
[Musique]
vous êtes très organisé vous avez tout
ce qu'il vous faut à manger de quoi
jouer
pourquoi vous aimez venir ici il ya
plein de gens on voit des films étranges
on peut partager ses boissons ça bouffe
dans la ville on ne peut pas boire
l'extérieur alors
en fait c'est surtout loire qui compte
non non non c'est que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
los angeles c'est autant l'endroit de la
superficialité que celui où l'on raconte
des histoires
de hollywood boulevard où l'on fait
piétiner les stars sur le trottoir à la
route sinueuse de mulholland jouahri
d'où l'on fait surgir d'étranges
créatures bleues
[Musique]
c'est dimanche et le week-end à la
périphérie de la ville il y a un tout
petit cinéma de 188 places qui n'a
projette que des films muets et des
comédies musicales
voici le hall tarn music roll rescapés
des années 20 c'est bill qui s'y
consacrent est lobé et l'ogc nice to
meet you stéphane
[Musique]
quand je rentre dans le cinéma j'ai
l'impression d'être dans une petite
boîte à bijoux
[Musique]
ou plutôt une boîte à musique quand je
découvre levure leader qui siège devant
l'écran c'est un orgue spécialement créé
pour accompagner les films muets un
objet aujourd'hui 1 racing
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à jouer de l'orgue quand
j'avais 12 ou 13 ans
je connaissais le propriétaire d'un
cinéma de los angeles
et il y avait un vrai heures
le patron était très heureux que
quelqu'un vienne et ça jouer de l'orgue
c'est comme ça que mon histoire avec un
joli devrait commencer
beaucoup de sons étaient dédiées à des
scènes précises
les scènes sinistre
[Musique]
il y avait aussi les scènes dans les
églises
[Musique]
pour les comédies c'était plutôt des
sont légers et rapides
[Musique]
vous voulez voir la collection de films
que j'ai à la gav
[Musique]
la boîte de pandora avec los boys
et
film muet de l'oral et hardi l'un de
leurs premiers films
[Musique]
tu aimes le regard dit oui bien sûr je
les adore tous les amis moi aussi vous
savez combien de fils les avait ici non
non
vous allez souvent au cinéma
oui je suis allé voir alice au pays des
merveilles est alors c'était bien vous
l'avez vu en 3d
[Musique]
c'était en 3d car j'y suis allé avec
quelqu'un qui voulait le voir en 3d
mais pour moi ce n'était pas de la 3d
car il faut avoir deux yeux et je suis
aveugle d'un oeil
alors je ne peux pas voir en 3 2
je m'en suis rendu compte que très tard
quand les premiers films en 3d sont
sortis dans les années 50 j'y allais
souvent et j'entendais toujours les
autres crié je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi parce que je n'avais pas les
mêmes sensations que les autres
[Rires]
je ne suis pas très fort avec tous ces
trucs électroniques
[Musique]
et parmi les centaines de films de sa
collection bill haas est préféré
[Musique]
c'est un extrait du film qui a remporté
le premier oscar en 1929 c'est wings
[Musique]
e
ils marchent bien de votre cinéma où
c'est compliqué parfois
toujours difficile
ouais pourquoi
waouh et bien
pour une seule raison
quand j'ai ouvert il n'y a plus de 40
ans la moyenne d'âge du public étaient
50 ans
m vous pouvez imaginer où ils sont
maintenant
[Musique]
ne pouvant plus assumer seuls bill se
fait aider par des bénévoles et sellami
def qui gère les entrées et le pop corn
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous aimez ici
j'aime les vieux films les films des
années 20 30 40
j'aime l'orgue j'aime l'entendre j'adore
l'atmosphère
vous savez à mon âge on est nostalgique
c'est un bel endroit
je le recommande à tout le monde
[Musique]
à
ok
aujourd'hui je vais vous jouer des airs
du film show boat et vous allez voir
c'est très beau j'espère que vous
apprécierez
[Musique]
rencontre
et
[Applaudissements]
depuis 1960 chaque séance se déroule
toujours de la même façon le show de
bile sur son orgue magique les habitués
qui reprennent les airs connus un film
muet un entracte et enfin le grand film
[Musique]
et pendant la projection bill fait les
comptes
mais omanais je suis fauché plus
d'argent sur le compte
mais ça va je fais ce que j'aime et les
gens aiment venir ici
sinon présence
aujourd'hui à los angeles il n'y a plus
d'endroits comme celui ci on peut voir
ce genre de film
c'est important d'être là
[Musique]
merci beaucoup il merci d'être venu le
temps d'avoir été avec vous et d'avoir
passé du temps dans votre cinéma
me voir c'est promis
prenez soin de vous
revenez on ira déjeuner ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
malgré tout les clichés qui lui collent
à la peau los angeles est aussi une
ville d'histoire authentique dans le
coeur baroque de la ville deux
révolutionnaires du cinéma paulo et lisa
après avoir sillonné leur pays et
montrer leurs films ce couple de
réalisateurs a décidé d'offrir une vraie
alternative aux films à succès
représenté par hollywood
soit un bus de l'armée qui carbure au
bio la plus petite salle de cinéma de la
ville
bonjour paulo salut mon ami tu parle
français
et italiens
alors tu va préparer le bus pour la
projection j'ai d'autres choses à
prendre je dois aller à l'intérieur
quelqu'un nous a donné ça aujourd'hui un
décès dans je ne sais même pas qui c'est
c'est quoi
chromatique
jeunesse c'est qu'on nous donne
régulièrement du matériel de cinéma
c'est pas dans le middle west que ça
arriverait mais ici ça arrive tous les
jours ceux ci appartenait à mon père tu
le veux inutilisés
depuis le début on voulait faire une
école avoir un cinéma à une coopérative
de films et là tu vois c'est un cours de
cinéma gratuit pour les ados ça les
cours sont gratuits oui en dix ans on
n'a jamais rien demandé ça fait partie
de notre mission c'est un principe enfin
montre aussi des films plusieurs fois
par semaine là il y à l'écran qui
descend on montre aucune sauf les films
de hollywood life ça va des films sur
les droits de l'homme à des films
espagnols des films gays tout ce qui ne
peut pas s'exprimer dans cette ville
c'est un rêve cet endroit est magique
c'est un rêve on a commencé cette longue
histoire mes parents étaient des
activistes il était très engagée
socialement et ils sont morts quand
j'avais 20 ans j'en ai presque 40
maintenant et pour honorer ce qu'ils
m'ont transmis je voulais créer un
endroit qui ne soit pas prétentieux qui
soient humbles dédié à la beauté du
cinéma est accessible à tout le monde
voilà comment tout ça a aidé c'est
vraiment un rêve mais c'est pareil bien
vivant
[Musique]
allez je fais partie de l'équipe heures
c'est pas si tu le sais mais ici nous
sommes dans le quartier de l'écoparc il
s'appelait avant endel et c'est ici
qu'est né le cinéma avec charlie chaplin
mack sennett t da barra américaine stone
cops tous ses premiers films ont été
fait ici tout le monde pense que c'est
la hollywood que tout est né mais en
fait c'est vraiment ce coin là
bon on n'annonce pas vraiment où on va
faire notre projection
c'est très secret on n'a pas de permis
pour le faire ces clandestins
aujourd'hui on va projeter un film et
croiser les doigts pour que les flics ne
viennent pas mais ça va aller
tu as déjà eu des problèmes
oui une fois un flic est venu et puis
s'est assise il a regardé film
pour toi et c'est comme ça que tu
envisages de cinéma qui doit l'amener
aux gens de cette façon ouais j'ai
longtemps travaillé pour limoux et j'ai
détesté ça je déteste cette hiérarchie
avec le réalisateur d'un côté
l'assistante production de l'autre et
cette sensation d'être plus important
que l'autre attend je fais le tour
il ya tellement de façons d'utiliser
cinéma on peut le faire de manière très
positive mais aussi comme de la
propagande comme du lavage de cerveau
moi je voulais montrer autre chose des
films qui racontent de vraies histoires
des histoires de passion alors tous nos
films sont virulents politiquement mais
ils sont vrais fait avec amour et
passion et le travail que nous faisons
avec les ados et honnête il vient du
coeur tout en ayant un sens et un fond
politique et activiste
moi je n'ai pas grandi comme steven
spielberg qui faisait les films dès
l'âge de 6 ans
il est j'adore ce média moi aussi
au programme ce soir un film sur les
fantômes du célèbre des l'ambassador là
où fut assassiné robert kennedy en 68 et
là où s'est déroulée la première
cérémonie des oscars en 29 essais juste
en face que paolo installe son micro
signer
[Musique]
si vous voulez voir le film c'est
gratuit
avant que le film ne commence nous
faisons une partie de bingo il faut que
tu participes
merci pour votre patience a tous notre
cinéma ambulant est un peu chaotique
mais la soirée que nous allons passer
ensemble va être très belle avec notre
cinéma on célèbre la ville et même si
notre écran et petit que la rue est
bruyante que nous flirtons avec le
désastre et l'illégalité nous sommes là
pour partager célébrer los angeles comme
un endroit où l'on peut vivre
si le lapin bingo si vous étiez triste
maintenant vous êtes heureux grâce aux
la part bingo
les feux lima
s
yes
c'est maintenant un an
pour les
[Musique]
cassis
et bingo
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous d'être là pour cette
nouvelle saison de nos projections en
plein air et nous sommes fiers de
commencer ce soir avec le film dicaire
fiction ce film est remarquable et
incroyablement beau et il a été réalisé
par pas tenir l'un des treize ans de
cette ville
[Musique]
m
je lève jacou normalement une telle
ouverture
bonjour
[Musique]
simpson et sa mine de sel
étonnant et pourtant il existe bien dans
ce trou paumé du kansas un rapport avec
le cinéma
il faut toujours que vous gardiez ça sur
vous c'est une petite bouteille
d'oxygène qui pourra vous sauver la vie
en cas de pépin en bas
[Applaudissements]
nous commençons la descente jusqu'à 200
mètres sous terre
nous sommes en train de franchir toutes
les strates de la terre et on va finir
tout au fond
[Musique]
dans le plus vieil galeries de la mine
de sel se trouve une mine d'or c'est ici
que depuis les années 60 tous les
studios de hollywood préserve tous leurs
négatifs originaux depuis l'invention du
cinéma jusqu'à nos jours plus de 150
mille mètres carrés pour des millions de
films empilés sur des étagères
bien à l'abri de l'humidité toute
l'histoire du cinéma américain est là à
mes pieds
il faut que j'étais de la lumière je
dois remonter travailler là où alors on
vous laisse tout seul avec une grosse
lampe est suffisamment de batterie
prenez votre temps et chercher tout ce
que vous voulez parfait je peux rester
ici aussi longtemps que je le veux oui
et si vous retrouvez la sortie vous
pouvez remonter
c'est parti pour la chasse au fil
[Musique]
un mad max ya'bad max il ya tous les
films d'elia kazan qui sont là
[Musique]
sauvez willy et dans un autre registre
sunrise waouh
alors là moi je vais tirer une bobine
moi je vais rester là
j'espère qu'ils vont oublier
parce que je suis bien au milieu des
toiles de l'amérique
[Musique]